is the mic work okay so i guess we're
starting to introduce myself so i'm
thomas Caswell I'm based at Brookhaven
National Lab and i'm currently kohli
developer of matplotlib and i'm here to
talk to you today about matplotlib since
this is a relatively small room if you
have questions during the talk please
just interrupt me that's probably better
than letting me just kind of ramble so
right so state is and we are very much
alive in an active project early this
year we signed an FSA with numb focus so
we are now a legitimate nonprofit target
in case you know anyone who wants to
make tax-deductible donations we can
deal with that so we have a very broad
contributor base so I heard of this I I
scraped get and got all the commits
since january first 2013 and if you do
that you get a graph that looks
something like this this is the
cumulative commits verse commit number
sorted committed number stored by number
of commits since we have a small number
of contributes to contribute quite a bit
however we have an extremely long tail
of contributors who I give us two or
three commits the unique contributors a
little off met the I think it's actually
like 340 there's some duplicates in them
and the email addresses right now but
you know so we're very big very big base
and also interestingly if you plot this
if you take this data and scrape it by
Aaron Bennett bye week the top graph is
the number of the number of commits per
week since 2013 and the bottom is
committers those two huge spikes in the
commits per week our syfy the sci fi
sprints for the last two years so we've
a pretty rare we were reasonably active
terms of other stats we have analytics
on our webpage we get something like
foreign 70,000
a month and Google thinks this is on you
know this is 190,000 unique users I'm
not sure I believe that number but
that's what Google says and if you look
at the times of the sessions you can see
p is definitely peaked as I by our and
you can see Peaks that I think
correspond to 10 a.m. London 10 a.m. new
york and 10am california and when these
are the rest of this various analytics
that come in places and is obviously
incomplete because there's a there's so
many distribution channels that there's
we have no idea how many what our
install base is i'll let it render rebel
but we have um that's not right okay
sorry so we're very very large code base
do something like ninety thousand lines
of code in the library and another
sixteen thousand in the examples holders
and in our history we go back to 2003
and there's history before this that
we've unfortunately lost so in the near
term we're actually in future freeze for
version 1.5 right now I mean are showing
you some some of the new features for 15
a little bit later and then one of the
main complaints reformat math olive is
our style as well as um well it's a
clone of matlab and that has become to
look very dated we are going to do a two
point O release that the only breaking
changes that are will be made or style
changes to the default styles so if you
have opinions on what the default style
should be make a pull request or an
issue telling us what they should be and
on August ninth of Mike drop boom and I
will have a phone call and sort out what
what the new styles will be and please
tell anyone you
opinions please tell them we want to
make sure we get as much input as
possible on this so in six months people
don't come to us and say but why didn't
you listen to me so and then we're going
to try to push up the tempo of our
future releases we have been doing about
once a year we're going to try to go to
twice a year on feature releases just to
get new features out faster and you know
faster you do release is the less
painful they are so all right okay sorry
I jumped ahead this is the style this is
how we're going to run the style changes
please spread it so now the fun part
demos so this is I'm gonna start with
stuff that's in the current release so
this is in 143 one of the big things
that is that is we have a functional
interactive backend for the notebook
this is a full live figure you have all
Mouse events keyboard events all these
things pass through to that if you've
done any of the event handling and the
the native client side you can do the
same thing in the web browser now and
this is the work of a good number of
people so so this is just a little sign
and you see if I click on it I get mouse
keyboard scroll works and this is just
this is just hooked up so any event that
comes in just changes the color of this
plus you can see it's doing as I claim
and just to be so Fernando walk in
yes so you know you know all the events
are there and you this stuff just you
know if it works on the native apps it
will work here we think I mean this is
something that it's we have it but it
used to be and these the tires kick I
mean we definitely need feedback on this
also just showing this off a little bit
more and plot 3d works just fine in the
notebook and
because you have you have all the call
back on the Python side you can do start
doing very rich you can do the same rich
interactions that you can do natively
for instance when i zoom on this one it
shows i'm on the right one it shows me
the box where i'm looking on the left
one and this is the code for this is
actually ripped straight from our
examples like this is just copying
pasting in the notebook and it works and
and again this you can Conda install
this right now another big feature in 14
that did not get enough advertisement is
Tony you give us the style module which
basically allows you to apply a partial
RC params file to your current session
so I'm cheating a little bit this list
here is what's currently on master not
what's in 43 when you say we have all
the seaborne styles and you can use this
both alright that one was a and the
style module we have a context manager
so you can apply these locally and you
can also do style dot use and apply it
globally you see this was supposed to be
a later example but what i'm doing here
is anything that looks like a path we
can deal with so you can actually give
it a URL and it will go out to the
internet and get your style file and
bring it down so if you have this
particular examples one of my co-workers
who's had an advisor in grad school was
very particular about plot style so he
has a jest that's just you know the
style file and every time his adviser we
could take something he just go add a
new line of the style file and then
included a you know a useless a knee at
the top of every every one of a scripted
notebooks and then from then on all of
his figures had that that change just to
show you that come on
alright so this is the same plot just
regenerate sit with whatever style you
want and as part of the default style
overhaul so the next problem for the
next for the reasonable future anyone
who puts in a reasonable stylesheet will
probably just merge and Shep it so if
you have a particular half style that
you you want we're happy I mean they're
small text files are happy to ship them
okay okay so now I'm moving on to
features that are on master in fact I'm
going to show you some things that are
only on a branch right now but so okay
so this is just a brief introduction to
the object hierarchy in in figures so
basically anything you see on the screen
is an artist as far as we're concerned
that's the object that's what we build
our scene graph out of the outermost
containers figure and that knows how to
translate from but it knows how to go
from its space to screen space when
you're rasterizing figures can contain
one or more axis spelled with an e each
axis this well Danny contains ver 2 T 2
axis spelled with an i which are
responsible for the limits and the scale
and then all the artists that are the
data you want to show are contained
within the hour children of the axes
with a net with an e so one of the
things we added is that artists now know
if they've changed since the last time
they were drawn so we can selectively
invalidate the scene graph which allows
us to do things like watch you know you
can install a hook and at your at your
embedding layer so in this case at the
notebook layer that after every time I
then execute code it checks of the
figures pipe lot knows about are any of
them stale and if so we draw those so
this allows us to do things like change
the line width and it automatically
redraws so one of the the so we have
basically we have to kind of parallel
API is a map challah bread with a
pipeline API which is a clone of matlab
and has draug interactive and all the
functions so when you type that that
function and then draws it and then
we've nabbed a grounded API which is
much more powerful more flexible it's
the way I think you should be doing
things but if you try to teach people to
do this at the repple you know you do
you say do bunches of 0 and then do vo
ax fig canvas draw which is you know
less than friendly so I think this
allows us to bring the full power of the
objects to the rapel and you know just
right so any any anything on these
objects that changes their state will be
reflected and if you do any embedding
because this is just a property on the
artists if your baby this is much larger
app you can use the same thing to
determine your draw cadence okay oh so a
a useful feature is that we are
frequently requested is to allow to
easily pass string labels into bar plots
so showing that off and another and if
you get the fonts right you can put
emoji in yeah so you can label regret
your graphs emoji if that's the thing
you want to do so another a project that
actually got spun out of matplotlib is
so right now built-in we have a color
cycle so if you want a psycho color
there's some subset of the plotting
commands that when you you know you do
plot it says oh I your start plotting
when you give you the third color but
constantly get requests for I want to
cycle my markers I want a second my line
width I want to cycle you know line
style which is you know not people are
becoming much more aware of
accessibility issues and needing to do
you know if you you know make sure thang
spent cleaning black and white make sure
you're colorblind friendly recycling
these other things is much more
important but doing going down the same
route of color and having a lion cycle
color this Klein cycle cycle sorry
a-line style cycle you know a marker
cycle the common torques if it just get
awful so this what cycler is this is a a
basically they're they're composable
cycles so they're constructed from a
label and then interval and when you
iterate over it gives you back
dictionaries of the key and value so for
a single one with just RGB so this is
just color RGB then I can do plus
and so now I have something I've add
them together now I have something that
when i iterate over mac dictionaries
with both both properties which to which
the way Matt followed by Liz you can
just now Stark art requires this into
any of our plotting functions and now
you're cycling more than one style at
once and we have both edition which
gives you lockstep zipping and we have
over light overriding star you get outer
product so this is a cycle that goes you
know cycles through colors and the
cycles line with end line style
internally so that's so that's that's a
own project that's under mat follow our
cycler please look at it kick the tires
it seems more general useful than just
matplotlib so alright so one of the
things that has become very clear to me
particularly in conversations at this
weekend is that we do need to be able to
handle labeled data and a clean way and
the the API we've settled on for the
first pass of this is I don't have a
good example of this is too fancy
basically if you pass a cord that's data
equals something that's supports get
item any arguments that are strings will
attempt to look up in that in that
object what does data is and then
replace it before passing it through to
the underlying function so how and sorry
this is a very fancy example of doing
this but allows you to quickly do things
like the UH anything that's particularly
well so what this is doing is I'm
creating I create a data frame which has
key sine cosine sine 2 cosine to I then
cycle over x over the keys the Y over
the keys adding some style to them that
is multiply those two cyclers together
and so now at each point in here I get
out of dictionary which is X Y and then
a bunch of style and then you can just
start Quogue that into a plot function
that knows x and y as named arguments
and you get this I mean you get this
graph out of very few lines of code this
is still a little experimental but I
think this is the this is the right path
to go for this okay oh and again if you
if you capture the artists we can always
do things like I would actually want all
my lines to be black and it just updated
all of them very quickly without having
to regenerate the plot ornate so this is
just this is the i mean there's a I've
only scratched the surface of the kind
of what we have in 15 this is damp the
big ones at the top but we have a number
of other things we have a we've added we
have some decorators planned that if you
have a function that takes an axis of
the first argument that will ensure that
you always have an axis so if you pass
one in explicitly we'll just use it and
if you don't it will do you know p ltd
CA to get you whatever the current axes
in crete won't create one if needed so
now instead of putting that same logic
and every single plotting function
everywhere her decorator that takes care
of it centrally and the rest of these
are just these are bug fixes small
features small quality of life things
that unless you use them and then for
the next release cycle the the big
features were looking at is working with
Steven Sylvester to integrate to
overhaul the notebook back end to
integrate with ipython widgets more
cleanly we're working with Brian Granger
and his student Ryan Ryan to add trait
lists to all of the artists so now we
get validate we get validation early we
get and then
we got the ability to hook all of this
into that whole ecosystem so now you'll
just feel to say here's an artist build
me a building a GUI for it in the
notebook and the kind of an
architectural thing is a brewin we're
looking at adding better container
classes so right now we have we have raw
artists you're like line and we have
collections which are really a
optimization at the low level and
they're always homogeneous artists you
know sly klein collection is of
collection you know all lines containers
are going to be a first-class artist so
will have its own position in the draw
and the scene graph and this response
for drawings children and it can be a
collection of homogeneous artists so the
poster child for the for this would be
error bar right now an eclair bar you
get back I think five or six artists
that are not don't know anything about
each other so if you wanted to go go in
and change you know dynamically change
your x and y positions of your points
you have to go in and touch the line the
caps the you know the Y errors in the x
ir separately whereas you grab those up
in a container you could put the brains
for doing that in that container so
that's yeah so that's that this does
anyone have any questions let me talk
without interrupting me yeah this isn't
anywhere public yet but um yes
I will I said that a scifi to mr. I'm
still turn up anywhere but i will i will
definitely try to get this up someplace
right so so the oh sorry no it'sit's /
it's not global so you should doing like
when you're just doing like line set
color yeah that's that's local to that
artist I think Brian can correct me if
I'm wrong but I think with trait 'let's
there are ways to globally touch all of
them Oh with trailas you can say I want
all my lines to be to be you know with
five now and all of your line objects
will suddenly be left with five so sorry
for putting on the spot
all right okay so either way okay so so
i also i want to very strong advocate
that all of you who are writing
convenience code for yourself to do you
know some high-level plotting then Matt
Paula provides in core you're surely
writing functions that have a signature
that looks something like like this it
should take in an axis is the first
argument so it plays nice with their
decorators to do the intern sure axes it
should take on data and then some style
and then it's I think I think ever more
else agrees with that mostly another
thing is that it's very I think it's
very important to return the artists
that you created that are relevant to
the data you just asked to plot because
it allows you to hook this into
interactive tools later example of this
this is a little plotting function that
just goes through a data frame looks the
columns you know use the information in
the data frame to label them correctly I
mean your plot them against the index
and then return them back to you in a
dictionary labeled by the column names
this is a bunch of ugly code for making
for building widgets that will be easier
in the future right so i have here i
just build build a data frame which has
sign and coat it has signed shifted
toward him back
and then I do this I get this figure and
then if I build myself the widgets Thank
You smaller can you all still see of it
right yes now I can do things like with
the widget make my lines wider you know
turn things on and off right so this
providing having your plotting functions
return the artist back allows the
possibility of building these very
interactive tools on top of the simple
functions that you're already writing
and again because you know we have all
the full mass events we have the full
picker events I don't plan it here but
you couldn't something where you click
on a line and doubles in with no so
again so if you're if you've got lots of
lines and you want to be able to
highlight one you know there's the use
cases for this get very quickly get very
large and then I'm going to skip through
that all right how am i doing on time
okay so the last thing I want to say
something about where matplotlib over I
think Matt pot lib should be in the
community so it's the first thing we're
we actually are we're very friendly
we're just slow and part of that is
where we're mostly volunteer so things
happen nights and weekends and also we
have a lot of users like we can't break
things so which tends to cause you be
very conservative but we're always
looking for new contributors if any of
this seems to be ninety percent of what
you want and you want to help us like I
would love to talk to you and one thing
that's happened is that due to the many
users there's many uses of map
live well outside the domain expertise
of the core developers right where I'm
I'm a physicist by training your might
is yes there we have some other people
we have some astronomers but you know
there's no one on the core team that has
financed there's no in the core team
that does business analytics and we just
don't have that understanding of your
use cases and we really want to work
with people from those domains to help
them build the tools they need and to be
a substrate for building those tools as
clearly and effectively as possible so
yes this is basically end so I guess
I'll take questions but I just like yeah
I was going to say thank you to John
Hunter for giving us amazing foundation
and then this is the list of the 340 or
so people that have had commits in the
last year and a half so that's any
questions anything you wish you could
Lee is sometimes not the style of the
graph of the style of the code required
depending especially saying like
condition plots which are very useful
but what's a condition plot where you
want to condition when I do a series and
scatter plots conditioned on some other
variable like enough say you have a
pandas dataframe when you have some kind
of categorical variable the different
views of the same scatter plot
conditioned by that variable wind up
with using other libraries and syntax
it's like holy other some of the school
other stuff yeah so okay so yes we're
we're thinking about it so so I think
yes your think you're something this is
a crude example but this is you know
just plotting like a facet like this is
kind of what you do I mean right he
right here I'm just plotting comms
against each other but you know in this
for loop right it'd be this is easy to
say you know over that you know one of
my things I'm cycling / is what I want
to condition by and then you put just uh
whatever pandas computation you to do
there to get that
the condition plots like like a little
tile like if your conditioning on ranges
of a continuous variable I'm not sure
I've ever I'm not sure I've ever seen a
plot like that it just kind of goes back
to our saying before about like there's
a lot of there's a lot of places words
used heavily that we just don't know
anything anything and I guess my answer
is is the we're trying to force this at
the bottom to be this the clean API of
you know access data style returns
artists and then that's the foundation
to build these higher level more
interesting tools that you need records
again these low-level things I'm talking
about really are the most art single
access I'm putting one artist on one
axis which is very good from the low
level point of view but from the point
of view of a domain scientist or domain
expert who wants to say here's a data
frame make me the graph I want that's
something that core probably could never
support because they're just too many
use cases and also I mean this really is
a common thing everyone wants we're all
so enthusiastic about picking up some
sub-projects in the map of organization
if we have someone who has a plot you
know a kind of floss they want and they
want to work with us to build it we're
happy to host it under our umbrella and
work with you on that
yes it's in the faq which is which makes
sense I'm sorry I put it there so you i
can say that yes there's an example an
faq of usage of or suggest to style and
again and some of this will also get
better with the containers because now
you can now you can start pushing
towards these functions return a single
artist was either a raw artist or a
container which also know now because
what other questions is oh okay you've
got this thing you know that you've got
a function that's going to return six
artists now you have to figure out what
how to structure that in a way that
makes sense across everything as the
answers you put that in a container that
makes this a lot easier that's doesn't
that code doesn't quite exist yet so I
mean there's a prototype of it but it's
not the test don't pass anything else
I
yes just because the the there's so much
stuff that wants to use it in very
specific ways and either we just pick up
a comet Oracle II insane number of
functions that again we don't know the
domain expertise to support correctly
like an example this is the finance
module you know we have it it more or
less works but every so often we get
issues that like we're doing these
graphs just straight-up wrong and
there's no one the core team that can
evaluate that statement I mean I
definitely like to encourage all the
stuff built on top of us to be as common
as possible in terms of you know
patterns and styles I mean there's
probably some some stuff that will end
up in core that you know if there's six
there's six things built on top of us
that are all use doing the same thing
then that's something that you move down
to us but yeah that's everything
something I didn't I didn't I was we're
talking very we're working with the
bouquet folks try to make sure there's
interoperability there's a be some
language we can speak between these two
and we're working with them to thinking
about how to design these high level you
know how high level things are you hand
in a data frame and it creates sixaxis
for you like that's that's not really an
API we currently have and trying to
understand the best way to parametrize
that and the best way to do that is
definitely an open problem
yes that's going to come out of the
trailas and basically once once the
entire scene graph is composed of
artists that have trail it's even ask
those artists what are your properties
that we've bothered to trait and we're
saying that those are the important ones
NBC right now we have a draw function
which basically walks the scene graph
and renders we're going to end up with a
parallel you know export tree walker
that will walk and ask all the artists
in this in the scene graph to tell me
what your dictionary is and then
probably you can you'll be able to
provide it you know something callable
to consume those dictionaries and now
it's very easy to write pluggable I'd
like to export to this format so you
know one idea is have you know hdf5 file
representation of your plot yes that way
you can clued huge data without a
problem and you but this is using the
same machinery you can export a JSON so
we can send this to Boca if you want to
see this in a dashboard and conversely
since we'll be able to since we'll be
able to consume data structures like
that book you can say oh you want a PDF
ship it in that problem and will give
you the high quality you know
publication ready PDF of your graph I
mean that that boundary is still very
very fluid but well I'm optimistic we'll
get that sorted out there's a definite
motivation on both sides to make that
work
anyone else anyone have general
matplotlib drapes let's still have two
minutes we have an entire redo that in
our test suite via image testing so
basically have a basically you have a
baseline image of what it should look
like and we've got machinery for
rendering it to ping SVG and PDF and
then comparing them to make sure they're
closed that is a hippie I uh yes and
I've not thought about that at all I
mean I mean
and so I can see the connection to NB
greater and what they're trying to do on
the other hand from the point of view of
plotting if I'm if I draw my graph with
one line with Nan's in it do to break
that to break it up or 15 line 2d
objects or a single line collection at
some point I don't care as long as it
looks the same on the screen so I'm not
okay so that the comment was that for
for user for user land users want to do
this kind of testing to make sure their
plots are coming rap coming out right up
there plotting code without having to
all the image comparisons so yes
probably providing an easy framework for
that might be something we should do
maybe that's true yeah so all right I
think that's my time ok Oh